here we see the famous surgeon with its
general prick leanness not exactly the
most mobile of sea creatures what did I
just say not the most mobile of sea
creatures unless that is an urchin ends
up as a hat for the Virgin crab this
isn't a gag and it isn't an anomaly is
just what the Virgin crab does because
while crabs may be evil crabbing pinchy
they're no match for big predators by
donning the urchin as a hat the crab
assumes its defenses well it may seem
like nothing more than an embarrassment
for the urchin it actually doesn't get
such a raw deal the crab ends up
transporting it to new feeding grounds
that means the urchin gets more food
without expending the energy getting
there on its own even more elaborate are
the decorator crabs to blend in with
their environment they stick all kinds
of materials to their shells from
seaweed to coral their trick is tiny
hairlike structures that snag the
decorations and hold on tight and indeed
the hooked hairs look exactly like
velcro so the next time you can't decide
what to wear roll in glue and stick on
everything around you it's called
fashion surprised you hadn't heard of it